[Musique]
le vol est sécurisé mais je ne peux pas les
joindre par radio, ils doivent être en
panne quel est votre statut
déjà ici
Yury je pensais que vous aviez dit que c'était sécurisé
c'était allons-y peut-être que ce n'est pas aussi grave qu'il n'y
paraît  optimisme mais d'après mon expérience
quand ça a l'air mauvais c'est généralement
pire attention  pour le centre de contrôle principal
et voir à quel point la situation s'est détériorée
Je vais rejoindre la fête
tout le monde retourne tranquillement dans vos
cellules et verrouille la porte derrière vous
[Musique]
comme un poisson dans un tonneau
qui ne sonne pas bien
je sais
j'espère que vous aimez la surprise araignée
surprise parle-t-il de hé regardez-moi juste
pris au piège dans une prison avec tous les criminels que
j'ai emprisonnés au cours des huit dernières années pas de
biggie
electro doit travailler pour quelqu'un
c'est trop beau pour être vrai
scorpion pouvez-vous tenir sur un  minute j'étais
au milieu  d'un appel téléphonique et c'était des
affaires
ne lâchez pas perdu une seconde là-bas
ok
ce n'est pas vraiment du rhinocéros électro et maintenant les
scorpions sont tous en liberté ce qui se
passe dans le reste des systèmes de caméras de la prison est
presque terminé je vais  je te donne
un sitrep bientôt d'accord je vais continuer à suivre l'
électro viens sur spider-man je pensais
que c'était un shake
gaah arrête ce gars
[musique]
si tu me dis pour qui tu travailles
je vais y aller doucement tu ne peux pas  arrêtez ça mais
je suis flatté que vous essayiez toujours personne
ne m'accepte jamais sur cette offre
ce que monsieur longtemps ne vois pas nous allons
avoir tellement désolé pas le temps de parler d'
accord j'ai remis les caméras de sécurité en
ligne comment ça a l'air
bien ça  on dirait toute la population
du tour
ça fait cinq de tes pires ennemis
qui sont maintenant en liberté pendant une seconde
là je pensais que tu étais sérieux je suis
sérieux je dois y aller certains d'entre eux se
dirigent vers la ville
ce n'est pas
ouais
ah
Continuez à chasser des soirées presque sombres
[Musique]
electro stop
comment aimez-vous mon nouveau costume
fringant où l'avez-vous trouvé c'est un club exclusif
[Musique]
rappelez-vous qu'il a dit de ne pas le tuer bonne
idée en fait nous n'avons pas à le faire du
tout si vous ne voulez pas nous vous voulons définitivement
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît
vous